hello GAO how are you I'm good you uh
I'm very I'm doing very well GAO tell me
where are you right now
um I'm in a small town called buriram
it's in the north eastern part of my
country uh I'm on a race weekend now so
I'm traveling and and you're in Thailand
is that right
yes in Thailand Okay Okay uh and and you
said where was he said he was doing what
a race some of the race weekend a race
weekend are you uh what's a race weekend
well uh basically in in motor racing as
a sport oh Motor Racing okay I thought
it was a weekend where people got around
and discussed racial issues
so very similar yeah I've been to a few
race weekends and they were not what I
thought they were it was very awkward
and I got very upset
um so are is that uh tell me GAO is that
your profession are you in the racing
profession uh yes I am
uh I work as a coordinator for a racing
team oh wow so so I I just make sure
that people get to places on time in the
race for just one time I mean you could
yeah I mean Matt brings up a good
question are you coordinating people
within the race or you just mean you're
making hotel accommodations and stuff
like that
well I coordinate all aspects of it so
uh anything that requires coordination
would be me okay we have a small team
during a race when your team is racing
have you ever had to contact a driver
and say we couldn't get you a Seaside
view we you're facing the courtyard has
that ever happened
well
um not during a race but I'm sure I've
told that to someone and they got quite
disappointed yes yes the worst call was
when you have to tell a driver you're
going to be your room is right next to
the ice machine that's the worst oh yes
yeah actually I'm sitting next to an ice
machine right now oh no you did it to
yourself no gal that's probably you
assuming the kind of guy who would put
yourself you would take a bullet for the
team you put yourself near the ice
machine so everyone else gets a good
night's sleep absolutely that's my sole
purpose of existing at all
that's really nice you seem like a good
guy tell me something do you come from a
racing family do people in the family
race
um yes my my father used to be a racer
before becoming a mechanic so he made a
name for himself by becoming a very good
mechanic he's one of the first people
who took
um Thai racing teams to Asian stage and
then you know uh we won Japanese
championships wow all of a sudden yeah
that's that's exciting so uh people in
in Thailand know know of your dad if
they know about racing they know of your
dad well I I don't think they know my
dad as Americans know you but uh uh they
do know I didn't say he was a beloved
National icon
um the very mention of his name uh
causes women to swoon
uh that would be an unfair comparison
GAO but
uh Swoon
it's like what's like a a really
desperate form of fleeing yeah
oh a fighter like a fight or flight
mechanism yes you were going to say
evacuating yeah both bowels and okay
there you go now I apologize for my
friends uh their crass and they don't
understand the ways of the world with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-proportioned ingredients I like
things pre-proportioned and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit that's
cool have you uh used hello fresh before
I have used hellofresh what I like about
them is they they do really give you
just what you need for the recipe yes
it's it's kind of hard to screw up and
I'm not insulting you but that would be
important wow it does sound like you're
insulting me but what I also mean is
even Sona can do it okay you know what
that I don't don't know that's a
compliment but I don't like that there's
stuff left over that's rotting in the
fridge if I'm not using exactly what you
need it is pre-proportionate and it's
recipes I never even thought about
making before which I love Yeah it
widens your uh scope as a chef go to
hellofresh.com teamcoco16 use code team
coco16 for 16 free meals plus free
shipping that's hellofresh.com team
coco16. hello fresh
number one meal kit so gal uh so your
your father uh is in the racing business
any brothers uh sisters in the racing
business well my my brother is also a
racing driver so he started yeah
actually uh you know when when you have
a father who's in who's in racing
uh that your parents tend to be quite
restrictive of you going to races or you
know chasing a racing career yeah but uh
my my brother snuck out to to drive uh a
car and raise a car so my father found
out and then he started a racing team
just for just to keep my brother in
check so that he doesn't go racing like
anywhere else that's a that's a
fascinating that's a fascinating
strategy you're race you're running out
there and you're racing instead of
saying I forbid this he said I'll build
a racing team around you
so that you I'll have at least some
control over your destiny he should try
to start a bank yeah I know
you want to start a bank do you I'll
give you a hundred million dollars
that'll show you
um so uh what is uh GAO tell me what is
what is your brother's name uh
uh noon it means no yeah kind uh very
close but uh it means number one in Thai
so very especially the same hold on a
second is he your younger brother yeah
wait a minute why is my older brother oh
he wait wait oh he's your older brother
okay okay that makes sense I thought for
a second I thought he was your younger
brother and they named him number one
and I thought what did you do gal he's
point five yes ah point five come here
say hi to one how do you race with the
name number one and ever lose and live
with yourself right
I guess
does he um what's his attitude like
what's tell me about your brother
uh it's uh yeah you got it
um yeah you got it uh what's my favorite
thing I'll do it every time you should
[Music]
um
what uh what's it what's he like compare
you know how are your personalities
different my my brother's you know if
the typical stereotype of uh a racing
driver is that the handsome uh the fit
and you know they are casanovas yes so
you know
picture a racing driver with all the
girls beside him yeah my brother was
kind of dead until he got married
so he's always the one with the girls
wow you know wow
let me ask you a question number one let
me ask you a question GAO um is it at
all difficult for you I come from a
large family a lot of a lot of brothers
is it all is it at all difficult for you
that
um you have a brother who's called whose
name is number one he's the first and uh
he's handsome and charismatic and a
Casanova and your father built this
whole team around him is it tough for
you do you feel like you're in
competition with your brother
I feel like I'm out of competition with
my brother more because I you know I'm
in a different League he's in a
different league so I don't think so I
know no I'm teaming now yeah number two
oh yeah yes our slogan is uh there's
there's a lot to do with number two yeah
nothing evokes a more pleasing image the
number two yeah no what's up cow you are
wrong I don't like you saying this about
yourself because I haven't met your
brother
um but I think that you are every bit as
important uh as as your brother every
bit as important as your body and I
think maybe even more so yeah and uh so
that's how I feel about this situation
GAO it's all about attitude I think you
need to start
um maybe changing your behavior a little
bit to make yourself number one in the
family do you understand what I'm saying
how would he do that okay I'll tell you
how to do it first of all you need to
start being kind of unpleasant no
um yeah and walking around like I'm in
charge here and enough of this oh I'll
I'll figure out which hotel people stay
and no you should be racing guy do you
ever race do you ever get in a car in
race
um I did but not professionally so you
mean just on the highway when you're in
a hurry oh yes
no um not really for re for legal
reasons
um no but
um I did raise a bit of go-kart when I
was young you raced go-karts
well I think go-karts are every bit as
respectable as any other machine on the
road and I think you should go back to
go-kart racing and become so good at
go-kart racing and internationally
famous at it that everyone forgets I
mean I can't even say his name you know
because he's so unimportant to me he
just said it yeah I don't think I said
it correctly did I I don't know I think
coordinating is important because it's
like you can race but if you don't get
to the race is there then you're just
going around in circles yes in the same
plane why not why be the second best
racer when you can be the best
coordinator
don't listen to them cow that's an
interesting take
yeah it's easy to be the host yeah right
exactly go
um these people are fools and Eduardo
you get near that mic again
and you're out of here see out of here
we got your back then yeah yeah all
right I'm gonna fire the guy who knows
how to work the equipment
who built a studio